( jungle sounds )
In the summer of 2011,
I visited the forests of Borneo,
the rainforest of Borneo,
for the very first time.
As you can imagine,
it was the overwhelming sound
that really struck me the most.
But in the background
of this sound,
this overwhelming cacophony,
is the sound of chainsaws.
In fact, if you turn down
the sound of the forest
there was actually
a chainsaw noise behind that,
- ( sound of chainsaw )
- the entire time.
It's very, very hard to know
where illegal logging
is taking place,
even over a short
distance of the forest,
because it's such a loud place
and because it's such
a dense place
that you can't move
through so easily.
So, here's this idea, right.
The moment that a chainsaw
goes off in the forest,
a computer, a device,
is able to pick up the sound,
pick it out of the rainforest,
the chainsaw,
and send an alert to
the local authorities
who can show up in real time
and halt the loggers.
But you need a device, right?
And so we're talking
about cell phones.
The amazing thing is that
there's sometimes
pretty good connectivity.
There's cell phone service out
in the middle of the forest.
To protect it from
the elements of the rainforest,
we put it in a box.
There's a powerful
microphone on it.
You do have to put some
solar panels on it
to make sure it
can stay powered.
This is actually what it
looks like all put together.
This is the prototype.
There's a phone inside that box.
And you're able to listen to
the sounds of the forest.
We were able to pick up
the sounds of chainsaws
and send a real time alert
to myself and to the
rangers that were there.